[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy analizamos las relaciones entre
la unión europea y el continente
africano pueden tener ambas regiones una
relación entre iguales la cumbre entre
la unión europea y la unión africana ha
significado algún tipo de avance antes
de pasar al debate vemos como han sido
las relaciones entre la unión europea y
áfrica en los últimos años
la unión europea y áfrica siguen sin
afianzar sus relaciones el pasado
colonial los problemas con la migración
y una mayor influencia por parte de
rusia y china- han provocado que europa
no haya puesto atención suficiente a uno
de sus vecinos más importantes mientras
más del 70% de los europeos están
completamente vacunados el continente
africano apenas supera del 11 por ciento
muchos países dependen de la donación de
los fármacos mientras los países más
ricos han acumulado dosis la unión
europea cerró rápidamente sus fronteras
al detectar la variante omicron
aumentando el aislamiento y el
señalamiento contra el continente
africano no obstante como un aliciente a
todas las medidas tomadas hacia áfrica
la unión europea ha reforzado la
creación de centros para que el
continente fabrique sus propias vacunas
y se ha comprometido a donar 450
millones de dosis en los primeros seis
meses del año en la más reciente cumbre
celebrada a mediados de febrero entre
ambos bloques los países de la unión
africana pidieron que se pasara de las
palabras a los hechos y que a europa se
comprometa cumplir sus objetivos de
inversiones
los líderes europeos aprobaron que se
inviertan en el continente 150 mil
millones de euros la unión europea es el
principal inversor extranjero en el
continente y quiere reforzar así su
influencia y evitar la omnipresencia de
china y de rusia en la región
y para analizar las importantes
relaciones que mantienen estas regiones
contamos con las eurodiputadas idoia
villanueva del grupo de la izquierda
europea bienvenida y doy a muchísimas
gracias me alegra estar con vosotros y
también con soraya rodríguez del grupo
renovar europa bienvenida es ahora ya
alabó encantada
primero de todo me gustaría empezar con
idoia la unión europea quiere volver a
revitalizar las relaciones con áfrica
pero ha dejado de lado europa durante
demasiado tiempo al continente bueno yo
creo que no podemos decir que europa no
ha estado presente en áfrica ni que no
hayan existido continuadamente esas
relaciones yo creo que lo importante es
partir de un análisis de darnos cuenta
de que no es una relación de continentes
de igual a igual sino que partimos de
una relación donde un continente
colonizó a otro continente y eso
arrastra
muchas de esas relaciones yo creo que es
parte de nuestra historia y que es
importante tenerlo siempre en cuenta
para poder hacer un análisis de esa
situación
como decía europa
comparte con áfrica mucho más
fronteras y esas relaciones
han sido han venido arrastradas como
digo de esta historia nuestra y
desgraciadamente muchas veces han estado
basadas en solo intereses económicos o
en explotación de recursos en vez de ese
desarrollo de igual a igual y compartir
de igual a igual como continente yo creo
que ahora en esta nueva rehabilitación
de esas relaciones y de ese
fortalecimiento tenemos una gran
oportunidad para que ese desarrollo sea
en base de igual a igual y que los
derechos humanos y fundamentales no
estén supeditados al desarrollo de los
países la cumbre unión europea unión
europea unión africana ha podido
revitalizar estas relaciones se puede
llegar a tener una relación de igual a
igual como comentaba idoia si yo creo
que esta cumbre tenía grandes
expectativas porque bueno primero
nosotros la unión europea había aprobado
una nueva estrategia unión europea unión
africana en preparación de una cumbre
que se tuvo que suspender por
la pandemia por lo tanto era una cumbre
muy esperada
un elemento fundamental es este no
reconducir nuestras relaciones a dos
socios iguales para mí qué significa
realmente esto significa no que en los
dos continentes seamos iguales porque es
evidente que no lo somos pero sí es
evidente que tenemos retos a los que
ninguno de los dos ni de europa ni
áfrica puede hacer frente solos y por lo
tanto tenemos una necesidad compartida
yo creo que este es el foco que cambia y
que debe cambiar desde una de un foco en
el que en años durante muchos años ha
estado enfocado mucho en la relación
donante-receptor
entonces yo creo que ver a áfrica como
un socio absolutamente necesario no
solamente política económica en retos en
materia energética cambio climático
seguridad paz es realmente el nuevo
impulso que necesitábamos lo hemos
conseguido bueno hay algunos elementos
para la esperanza pero al final después
de la cumbre hay una declaración lo
importante es el camino que comenzamos a
transitar
la unión europea ha prometido una
inversión de 150 mil millones de euros
sólo en el continente africano a través
de la iniciativa conocida como puerta
global y así hacer frente a la conocida
como ruta de la seda china es un cambio
esto ya en las relaciones de acabar con
esta relación durante receptor que
comentaba soraya bueno yo creo que es
una buena noticia todas estas
iniciativas en un mundo tan
interconectado y tan globalizado de
alguna manera que haya estas iniciativas
de impulso entre los dos continentes
como veníamos diciendo
cambiar ese modelo de donante o receptor
o cambiar ese modelo donde europa en
determinados momentos ha puesto la ayuda
al desarrollo condicionada al control de
fronteras oa la migración en vez de ir a
la raíz del asunto y trabajar el porque
tenemos ciertos problemas en la raíz de
lo que está ocurriendo creo que esto es
una oportunidad es verdad mencionabas la
ruta de la seda que hay intereses
adicionales e intereses cabeza
adicionales de china y de rusia pero que
no son muy diferentes a los europeos en
este sentido a desarrollar también
económicamente sobre sobre el continente
africano y yo creo como decía antes que
esta cumbre el fortalecimiento de estas
relaciones tienen que ir al origen
de esa relación no ya fortalecer pues
ese entendimiento y poder afrontar de
forma común los retos globales como la
transición energética como el cambio
climático y también hacer ese giro y ese
cambio en la relación unión europea
áfrica
ahora ya me gustaría
justamente ha ido ya comentaba sobre
rusia y china que han estado muy
presentes también en el continente china
a través de inversiones millonarias
rusia también con el grupo de
mercenarios wagner muy presentes sobre
todo en mali puede llegar ahora europa
tarde está llegando tarde ahora pero yo
creo que no europa no llega tarde porque
europa
está en áfrica y hemos mantenido y
mantenemos una fuerte relación no
solamente relaciones diplomáticas sino
también indudablemente relaciones
económicas
relaciones institucionales y una fuerte
presencia de europa también en el
compromiso de las misiones de paz y de
búsqueda de la estabilidad lo que sucede
es que como todo en el mundo europa no
está sola el marco el tablero
geopolítico es muy importante y es
verdad que quien ha acelerado su
presencia en los últimos años ha sido
china y rúsia pero yo creo que está
claro y es evidente y también muchos
africanos y sobre todo la sociedad
africana lo está viendo los intereses de
la unión europea y los propósitos de la
unión europea no son los mismos que
tiene china o que tiene rusia en el
continente concretamente ha citado el
grupo wagner es un grupo de mercenarios
financiados por putin cuyo objetivo es
claramente el contrario de la unión
europea que está participando codo con
codo en misiones de paz con
instituciones regionales africanas y con
países africanos
nuestro objetivo es estabilizar buscando
desde luego el trabajo institucional es
decir fomentar
pilares de la democracia que son el eje
fundamental sobre el que se sostiene la
paz y la estabilidad de los países
mientras que rusia con estos grupos de
mercenarios lo que busca precisamente es
desestabilizar no solamente jugando con
el territorio sino jugando con la
población por la otra parte china china
ha tenido una actividad enorme desde el
punto de vista de inversión pero ya se
están viendo los resultados en muchos
países donde el grado de endeudamiento
de estos países está llegando a cuotas
históricas su inversión ha ido dirigida
fundamentalmente a grandes empresas
chinas que
realizan los proyectos en áfrica y este
nuevo proyecto y en el que nosotros
queremos trabajar para el 2030 es un
proyecto de muchísima más colaboración
con el tejido empresarial
africano y sobre todo quisiera citar que
hay una nueva mirada en este nuevo
paquete de inversiones y es una mirada a
la sociedad africana estamos
acostumbrados a recibir noticias siempre
en negativo de áfrica golpes de estados
situaciones de hambruna catástrofes
humanitarias pero hay otra realidad de
la que no informamos pero si existe y es
una sociedad formada por hombres y
mujeres muy jóvenes que han tenido
acceso a la formación que han tenido
acceso a las universidades y que son
ahora mismo el elemento el vector más
activo del desarrollo económico de
áfrica pequeñas y medianas empresas
empresas digitales con esas empresas
tenemos que trabajar desde la unión
europea y hay algunos programas muy
importantes como es llegar al 2030 la
digitalización total del país en
inversiones conjuntas que me parece que
es vital por lo tanto no llegamos tarde
hemos estado pero para mí lo más
importante significar que estamos de una
manera muy diferente a la que está china
o rusia en áfrica en esta cumbre unión
africana-unión
europea se ha hablado también de la
posición de las vacunas
sudáfrica sobre todo está insistiendo
mucho en que se liberen las patentes
pero la unión europea lo sigue
bloqueando
puede ser ésta la solución es necesaria
esa liberación de las patentes no creo
que es evidente que estamos viviendo
como el continente africano está a un 8%
de doble pauta de vacunación y hemos
aprendido en esta pandemia que solo nos
salvamos si se salvan todos no depende
de que algunos continentes o como europa
tengamos 3 4 ó 5 dosis de vacunas
mientras hay amplias poblaciones en el
mundo que no pueden estar siendo
vacunadas y donde esas nuevas versiones
del virus se están creando y hacen no
que tengan implicaciones en el mundo
entero es evidente es un ejemplo de cómo
una vez más ha conseguido el interés
económico estar supeditado a algo como
una pandemia que tantas vidas humanas se
han llevado por delante y tanto destrozo
ha hecho social economía psicológico en
las poblaciones por lo tanto es una
iniciativa que desde luego nosotros
hemos impulsado desde el inicio y
pensamos que es esencial esa liberación
de las patentes que muchas veces han
estado financiadas también con dinero
público en la investigación y que
deberían estar puestas al servicio de
derecho común que es el derecho a la
salud
muchísimas gracias a las dos lo siento
muchísimo porque nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo y doy a soraya gracias por este
importante debate también hay que hablar
sobre estas cuestiones gracias a las dos
a ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de europa hoy gracias por ver
france24 en español
[Música]